the topic of our discussion today is
poverty globalization faith traditions
and poverty alleviation we've troubled
kind of a long way in this course right
from the let me sketch what we've
covered right from the very beginning
few remarks about pluralism and
exclusivism right remember those lecture
those those comments at the very very
beginning and maybe I hope that as the
class has progressed their significance
have become more apparent to you and
then last time we kind of picked up
again on that discussion with with tony
blair present and it continues to be i
think a very important issue for us
sketching first the world of faiths
especially the discussion of
secularization versus D secularization
and maybe [ __ ] dipping in what we did
in this first full session is just to
understand what's happening in terms of
developments of faith and then next
session was about globalization and then
ambivalence ambiguity of globalization
having this shadow side as well as what
is normally celebrated positive side in
terms of both economic fostering
economic prosperity cultural interchange
whole host of things but nonetheless and
registering very significant downsides
of course there are discussions and they
bear on our conversations today whether
in fact the poverty that we see to what
extent it is caused by globalization
processes and to what extent we need to
rethink not just some people would say
not just how globalization is being
conducted quote-unquote but whether
globalization as such whether the system
of which globalization is part is indeed
viable system for the planet and for the
peoples we haven't quite asked that
radical question but that radical
question is there in the air right with
the critics of globalization processes
with the critics of mmm how things are
being done normally and I think it's
important at least to keep in mind that
there's also this
side of the discussion we've talked in
quite a bit about economic side of
globalization both in terms of
overarching framework for economic
activity markets and values that shape
market as well as then paying attention
to what happens to the level of
individual corporation sessions then on
reconciliation that interfaith dialogue
and then now return back to the question
of economy from certain different angle
namely the question of poverty that's
common interest I think between faith
traditions and acting proponents of
globalization is somehow to improve the
lot of the poor faiths I think most
faiths there is a deep and abiding
commitment to the poor if you take
Christian scripture the same is true of
Koran other scriptures as well sacred
books as well a kind of strong sense
that those who as it says in the Good
Book
grind the face of the poor who head
ought to be resisted and not to be
resisted in the strenuous strenuous way
and there is this extraordinarily vision
right of everyone sitting under their
fig tree everyone having their own
sphere which they can control in command
which is a source of well-being
well-being for them but also I think
religious faiths have a history of
betrayal of the poor certainly that's
the case with the Christian tradition
where interest was not directed toward
them where a religion aligns itself with
the interests of power and forgets about
some of the most basic commitments that
religious traditions have now if you
shift and look at globalization and the
effects of globalization there too
there's a promise that a lot of the poor
will be improved and indeed there's a
claim being made that this is the best
way in order to alleviate poverty in the
world today and yet also there is this
trail I think of blood and tears there
is there those whose lot has not been
improved there those whose law has
become worse as a result of
globalization partly because of
displacement partly because of mainly
because of the tremendous and rapid
changes that are happening in the world
today on account of globalization
so the fact though many are still left
in poverty and I think that maybe we can
say at least that's what I would like to
argue that one of the basic tests those
four faiths and for globalization is
well how are we able to help those who
are the weakest in Christianity the
final judgement is based on the
treatment of the poor some of you who
know those texts in Matthew 25 when the
nations come together before the before
the before the judge then the judge will
say I was sick I was imprisoned I was
hungry you did not come in to my aid you
did not visit me you did not give me
food and he will say to you go to my
other side right I think increasingly
people are also aware more broadly that
the test for if efficacy of
globalization itself we have to think of
it also in terms of a maybe primarily in
terms of effects on the people who are
the weakest of all I would want to
suggest that the test of the humanity of
any system or of any society is how it
treats its weakest members whether we
are really interested in humanity right
in the human who is how you treat those
who can fend for themselves
those whose interests
do not necessarily in any way are
intertwined with yours those who could
you could afford to leave by the wayside
humanities that's the type of society of
a system how it treats folks of this
sort and I think in terms of fates and
globalization processes and especially
economic aspect over globalization they
may be kind of a mutual learning process
I know that often when it comes
especially to this issue there is
there's a strong conflict right faith
traditions many in the faith traditions
have felt need to protest against how
globalization is run and the same might
be in a different way true of the folks
who sit in some of the great
institutions of globalization like World
Bank right but the religions have to do
with this whole thing except to muddle
your thinking about what you should do
in order to alleviate a lot of the poor
right but maybe maybe faiths can learn
something from from the firm economists
and faith traditions I think have have
traditionally expressed concern for the
poor by insisting on equitable just
distribution but fates have not worried
too much about creation of wealth or
examining the causes of the poverty it's
almost like an assumption wealth is
simply there to be plucked as a ripe
fruit from trees surround right but you
got to make it somehow right and faiths
haven't much engaged this process or at
least you'll recognize that that's what
needs to happen so that you have
something to distribute so time might be
for faiths to learn that you can
distribute what you don't have and that
what you distribute may be of little
effect if you haven't attended to at
least in some way to the costs of
poverty
maybe global economic leaders can learn
from pay traditions as well that simple
stress on economic growth might not have
the expected effect on the poor
especially maybe
if fate traditions are taken seriously
and if effects then off the economic
systems are measured by our viability or
desirability of inoculum existence are
measured by the effects that they have
on those who are the weakest few more
comments and they concern and now
definitions of wealth and poverty but
what is wealth and poverty and when I
think about this I'm always reminded of
this fine book that isn't read these
days very much but when I was about your
age maybe a little bit older came out
which I thought was absolutely splendid
book and best book by Erich Fromm heard
of Erich Fromm to be and to have and
they said it's a book it's a book worth
reading or google it and get the basic
gist of the thing and then you see
whether based on the google cliff notes
you might want to read it tonight I
suggested to you that you do he
distinguished between these two basic
modes in which human beings as it exists
a mode of being and mode of having
having mode of having is a kind of mode
of life marked by desire to infer
acquisition for consumption for
possession of things and the mode of
being is marked by generative action in
the world and by experiencing the world
and by living authentically oneself
that's a kind of rough sketch of these
two of these two modes and then you can
think of wealth and poverty in both of
these modes and it looks very different
before you look at it in those two modes
if you look at wealth in the heavy mode
well then it looks like the stuff of
various kind some stuff is very tangible
some stuff is in kind of ethereal but
nonetheless you can describe it as as
stuff that one obtains to consume or to
control
and the question then becomes whether up
above certain threshold that's necessary
for survival even in the mode of having
is what's considered wealth simply a
matter of stuff I would want to suggest
that even in the mode of having wealth
is not simply stuff but wealth is
concerned with psychological attitudes
as well as social relations something is
considered wealth in the context of
certain social relations and not
abstractly in and of itself let me give
you example you take for instance for
instance a gift take something as a gift
now you walk through through through on
the street and you saw a you see a gift
shop right and what is sitting in the
gift shop are all gifts are they there's
stuff right they're not gifts they're
stuff that when you buy it with certain
intention to give something to somebody
else becomes a gift but it's not a gift
as a thing in itself right
it is a gift when it enters into this
exchange between people that one person
buys something to give to something else
now it's a gift before it was a thing
sitting on the shelf now I think that
something is similar is true of wealth
as well it's not simply stuff I think
it's also social relations what is
considered poor or wealthy depends not
on amount of stuff Robinson Crusoe alone
on an island is he wealthy or not I
don't know right
our Marx gives a typical example right
of a relative character of wealth in and
if the character of wealth is relative
then it means that social that wealthy
is a social real a
right a guy has a has a home very nice
little two-bedroom cottage and next to
him somebody builds a mansion and
suddenly what was very fine house right
turns into into a shack overnight
because there is a comparative
relationship between these with these
two I think it's important that at the
level even of having we think of wealth
not simply as amount and quality of
stuff but as a social relation now let's
go into wealth in the end poverty in the
being mode you know in terms of
possessions you can be rich indeed you
can be the richest person in the world
and still be poor ah you can called it
as never enough person you've
encountered folks like that right it's
kind of you are never enough no matter
what you do some of us have parents who
are like that right in regard to our
achievements they're kind of never
enough folks no matter what you do it's
not quite right you've got to achieve
certain higher goal than than that right
and jorgen is the whole life in terms of
then amassing and then you never quite
have enough I think anthropologically
that's rooted in in human finitude we
are finite beings right we are needy
beings and without satisfying these
needs without us not having enough
somehow right we always do not have
enough because we need to have more
things in order to continue to live but
I think it's fundamentally rooted in our
self transcendence because you are
always beyond anything that you have
actually reached right you can always
imagine yourself a step ahead and you're
always in a sense stretched so your feet
are on the ground but your arm is
somehow reaching somewhere beyond where
you are and into the Stars right so
that's the self transcendence
of human-beings that's where this
permanent if you want to say
dissatisfaction never enough is is
rooted but it's strengthened I think
culturally for us strengthened by these
comparisons which we always make and
it's strengthened in particular I think
in the market economies because market
economies are predicated not just on
satisfaction of desires right but on
generation of desire yet to be satisfied
that's how the thing functions and
sometimes that's a very good thing right
because that's how progress happens
that's where how we have iPhones and
things of that sort right we but that's
also how the whole way of existing as
permanently being dissatisfied as a
condition of possibility of advancement
advancement happens it's a question what
do we do with this at the
anthropological level bracket your
anthropological experience you think of
it economical you think of course you've
got to generate those needs right and
you have to motivate people to satisfy
those needs then the economy's is moving
think of it in terms of one's own
experience of the self or being in the
self being with others and then I think
things somewhat shift alright and one
experiences it maybe in a different way
so you can be a richest person in the
world and be never enough person you can
be poor really poor I mean and unless
you are starving don't have clean water
or adequate shelter you can be more than
enough person life then has been
organized maybe around generative acting
and proper enjoyment the happiest person
that I've ever encountered I think I
talked about her in this class was my
nanny
she had nothing absolutely nothing lost
her husband in World War two did not
have a place to live
came to our family because we had three
rooms and she had not and I still to
this day have not met person who was Jen
more genuinely satisfied than she was
and she was you know enjoying life right
as I mentioned before she was singing
all the time
very poor but kind of more than enough
person it's rooted maybe in generative
acting all other things being equal are
you richer when you have helped dig a
well in an African village or when you
have acquired a new iPad or say
enjoyment all other things being equal
are you richer when you have understood
plato's you through phone or when you
have acquired thousand bucks so I think
I think it's important for us to think
about what wealth actually means and how
to understand well indeed I think that
one of the great issues before us is to
reflect on the character of wealth and
character of poverty
so and especially since if it's true
that economy is the driver of
globalization processes and if it's true
also and some of you may doubt that
right that the really big important
questions in life are questions of what
this whole thing that we are engaged in
is for footnote into these comments two
days three days ago I was sitting
sitting here and we had a conference of
Jewish and Christian thinkers or
theologians rabbis whenever there was a
working group of us and we were
presenting our results of our work and I
gave a paper I wrote a paper on human
flourishing in kind of Christian Jewish
and on the side also Muslim traditions
there was a friend of mine who did the
same thing also and law professor Tony
Cronin was responding to a stirring and
you can see why we chose Tony Crown man
right because he's interested in the
questions of large questions of the
meaning of life and how they bear upon
on our lives and we were sitting there
and after we've finished this discussion
then he leans to me and said Miroslav
when I say to my some of my friends that
these questions of metaphysical
questions that we were discussing the
questions of moral order of the way to
understand self and relations human
relations the good what is the good that
we're pursuing when I say to my friends
some of my friends that these are more
important questions more crucial for us
than how to fight terrorism and you can
go down the line they laugh at me but
it's maybe important to stop and pause
and ask the question whether indeed the
large question how should we then live
is a fundamental question that we need
need to be asking certainly they have
consequences for how we understand the
bearing of wealth on happiness you
remember that we had this discussion
Tony Tony and I here after we read this
Hershel claimed that there was no
improvement in happiness from Stone Age
to to to today right
well I had it may be it may be debated
and Tony was responding and well we none
of us wants to return and that's that's
true
but what does that prove right except
that we may be mistaken about what truly
satisfied maybe that's the lesson from
this and maybe that's the in a sense the
difficulty the bind that we find
ourselves and obviously no but I don't
want to go back right
so it's not misunderstand I'm not
advocating going going back but is it
possible to ask the question in a
different way and to reorient ourselves
away from stress on kind of means
acquiring the means of living instead of
living from having to to be I think
that's the large question that the faith
traditions oppose and I think that's
also maybe a large question that is
surfaces for us in the context of the
crisis in which we find ourselves today